from fox 5 dc proud boys leader enrique
tario arrested in dc
police say fox 5 has learned and rick
guitar has been arrested
evan lambert reports tario is facing
misdemeanor destruction of property
charges in relation
to him saying he burned a black lives
matter flag that was stolen from a black
church in december
during a protest in the district lambert
tweeted two law enforcement sources
confirm and ricky taurio has been
arrested
on dc misdemeanor destruction of
property charges d.c police confirmed
monday evening they had arrested the 36
year
old he has been charged with destruction
of property related that offense
police say at the time of his arrest
tario was found to be in possession of
two high-capacity firearm magazines
he has been additionally charged with
possession of high-capacity feeding
device
so i guess that's related to the
magazines that's the crazy thing people
don't know about dc
you can't even own ammo oh you have to
get a register you have to get
registered to own ammunition it's like a
lot of places don't even do that some of
the craziest places
it's all about the guns they say earlier
on monday the metropolitan african
methodist episcopal church in dc filed a
lawsuit against the proud boys and
taurio
alleging that the group scaled its fence
and tore down a large black lives matter
sign on display
it was one of two historically black
churches that were vandalized during the
protests
so they made that statement and they
called it like they were saying it was a
hate crime and stuff like that
and so it was a bunch of proud boys who
apparently done it in my opinion i don't
think you should be
you know taking private property and
burning and destroying it because i'll
criticize antifa for the same thing
but i guess because they were calling it
racist and ricky tario who's not a white
man
posted on parlor that it was actually
him and and he said something like
i dare you to charge me with a hate
crime are you guys familiar with
what he posted oh yeah and actually we
were there that night and we saw this
stuff i think you were you were there
right beside me
and i can tell you two things number one
nobody knew these were black churches so
like this idea there was a bunch of
white people walking around hunting
black churches number one
this is washington dc so the chance of a
church probably being a majority black
church is pretty high since this is a
very
dense black community but number two if
you understand the entire political
spectrum of proud boys there's like two
groups they oppose
and that's antifa anarchists and then
like communist back groups
which many people who helped found blm
claimed to be behind yeah so they
weren't seeing this i believe
why i obviously think it's kind of
stupid to tear something down and just
like burn it off of private property
i don't think this was a target on black
people i think this was like we're
taking down a communist symbol in a city
and showing that it's it we're taking it
back for america
but that's what i saw and that's what i
thought their motives were i think the
funny part about it is like
since when the hell does black lives
matter care about church
like um listen we were there we were
recover we were covering that right
on a saturday night the next morning
black lives matter dc held a presser
in blm plaza crying and complaining
saying that their black joy was stolen
and that all of a sudden they care about
church all of a sudden they care about
these historic black churches and it's
like
these are the same people that don't
want any form of religion even
whether it's jesus whatever it is
completely out of society so all of a
sudden black lives matter cares about
church but they just arrested a black
guy for doing it
and rickettario yeah literally he's like
he's half he's half black
they always try is he cuban or puerto
rican he's he's f they were
they report that he's afro cuban yeah so
i guess you know i think it's really
dumb because
i don't i don't like playing those games
on race with people like
i shouldn't have to bring that up about
what enrique's race is or anybody here
yeah but you got to flip it on their
head man but when they
say it was a bunch of white dudes
stealing you know black joy or whatever
it's like
actually the guy who claimed he's
claiming he did it i don't know if he
was he was that he did but
i mean it sounds reasonable but he's
he's like the proud boy he was there
can we just say this though that night
this happened not only were a couple
proud boys
stabbed um from what i remember right
weren't they critical yeah they were
stabbed
but also can we also can also point this
out that antifa were also looking to
attack proud boys at this time
black lives matter the organization the
group shut down dc they were grouped
together
trying to attack the proud boys police
had to keep them off so this wasn't like
a war between white people and black
churches it's even worse there was a
battle between
blm and t for activists and and the
proud boys and so they're like kind of
like how antifa keeps ripping down
american flags and burning them
because they think that proud boys
symbolize american patriotism they kind
of went back and said well let's rip
down their signs
too stupid probably but stupid you know
i think it's even worse than that elijah
because they're they're not only
going after proud boys antifa black
lives matter and dc are going after
innocent trump supporters you have like
elderly couples you have young people
that just support the president that are
walking down black lives matter plaza
just back to their hotels getting
physically assaulted because of
supporting the president so it's like
the media will take this and say
oh the proud boys are attacking black
people but the reason why the proud boys
responded was because
innocent trump supporters were being
physically assaulted all night long the
past two events
and the mpd because they have their
hands tied they just kind of
shoot them away and continue and move on
and move on one of the top stories on
reddit just a few days ago was this
church
actually suing the proud boys and now we
have the washington post
confirming that he was arrested
specifically for burning
the black lives stolen banner this is
washington post just reporting on it
right now so
is it for the arson or for the theft
it's misdemeanor property destruction
it was it was oh now dc cares
about property destruction it's more of
it it's great right
this is the timeline we find ourselves
no but but look at what's going on right
now with like that leaked phone call
from trump right
it's a leaked phone call and twitter's
like oh that's fine
didn't we just go through this huge news
cycle of like you can't release people's
private information
or them doing specific substances with
uh i'm not even going to say that the
double standard
is pal but this is the point i want to
get to that's actually it's actually
pretty worrying man
when the proud boys romped around dc
there's a video of them
really just clobbering this antifa dude
now apparently
there's like an antifa guy who was
fighting with him got separated from his
group him and this chick
and then the proud boys just would not
relent this guy's trying to leave he's
clearly lost the fight and the proud
boys run up one one guy grabs the woman
a proud boy a guy grabs a woman by her
ponytail and like pulls her hair back
and i'm like dude that is that is that
is loser antifa style fighting
grabbing a woman's hair from behind and
point you're a dude come on
but repeatedly pummeling this guy this
antifa dude
as he's clearly no threat to you or
anybody else then they went and they
tore down that that sign out
my response was like sounds a whole lot
like what antifa does i'm not a fan of
that
if you want to defend yourself from
antifa you you should you should
absolutely defend yourself from somebody
wants to beat you up who's
attacking you or defend others but when
they're running away tail between their
legs pathetic
let them go yeah but see drew brought
this up and i think this is where people
don't understand i'm not defending
the violence because my i myself am not
like an extremely violent person not
even mildly violent people even like
discredit me or try to slap me on the
face for the fact that like oh hey
you know you should fight back a little
more and defend yourself but when i see
those events you have to look at the
whole timeline and from the very
beginning these
antifa groups which are often protected
by the mpd they have
a reserve base it's the black lives
matter plaza
which essentially is like 14th street or
whatever right there by the
white house yeah right by lafayette
plaza park
and they get they they run back to this
area protected by police then they come
out
of the sides the police let them leave
and come back but nobody else so if you
look like you're in black block or
whatever you can go in and out i've
experienced this if i'm wearing black
block i can get in dress like a
journalist no
so you go in they come out they like
fireworks
they assault people with skateboards
they punch people they hit people
all the time the guy watches happening
so when the proud boys aren't just like
going there and being like
let's go pummel some antifa let's go
pummel some black lives matter it's like
these guys are extremely masculine men
who
a lot of them it's a part of a club i'm
sure a lot of them feel a lot of the
same reasons why people might join
antifa they might have been
you know feel a little bit rejected from
society some of them and they found a
lot of camaraderie and brotherhood
there's
some positive elements here but they get
riled up because the violence starts
happening and they go and somebody's
always like
we need to fight back we need to show
these people they can't keep assaulting
us if the police won't step
in then we will but here's the point i
want to make the proud boys used to be
very conscious about press
they'd be very very careful they'd make
sure they know the media is looking to
smear them all the time
so they would try their best but no
matter what the proud boys do
they're a far-right white supremacist
group literally you got
enrique taro not a white guy and they
claim he's a white supremacist it's a
weirdest thing this this
so when they when i think they've come
to the point now the proud boys have
realized
there's no point in even trying to do
the right thing yeah as
as as far as the press cares because
they're going to get lied about anyway
so now they're just like screw it we're
going we're going to gonna we're gonna
go out and and
you know we're gonna do what antifa does
why not spot on the relationship between
antifa and the police is something
that's
really peculiar because there have been
many documented instances of police
officers
dressing up as antifa and then
committing property destruction
as has happened throughout many protests
and now to hear your reports of them
kind of cuddling them
like what's the most egregious example
that you saw of this or or like how
would you
what would you say sticks out to you
most uh this is how this is how it goes
down um
you will literally see on one of these
nights you will literally see antifa
black lives matter
start they they start these violence
they start these violent acts they'll go
after innocent
trump supporters it's not proud boys
you'll see like elderly couples walking
down the street
teenagers young kids the first mega
rally
was they were holding down the fort
black lives matter plaza
they issue out text messages saying we
have to defend our territory we have to
defend blm plaza
and whoever's wearing a trump hat
whether it's an elderly person or a
young kid
they will go to town on them so when
that happens the police will just shoo
them away
and then the proud boys will see that
like all night long and then they'll
respond to the violence
and come out on the streets because the
mpd isn't doing much
but what you do see is when the proud
boys come out
the mpd will literally grab antifa grab
black lives matter
pull them behind behind the line
i don't care what anybody says if anyone
wants to accuse me oh you're an activist
reporter i don't care i don't care at
this point there will literally be times
where i'm watching this and i'm like
these are the same people that have been
calling to defund the police all year
long and there they are being defended
by the police
and they they receive it we just saw
that in what salem washington yeah
where an auntie of a guy armed with a
paintball gun is standing
with his back to the cops staring at
proud boys and the pro
and is it i'm not even all proud by some
conservatives the craziest thing
seeing conservatives yell after the
police yeah i saw there was a dude
who looked like he was wearing proud
boys colors and he's screaming after
police after blue
and then you see that video this is from
ford fisher where they actually throw
the thin blue line flag on the ground
and start stomping on it
and then just chuck it into the street
police got no support left man well it
blows my mind i think the best example
to your point
of this is so there was polish state
media that were at the last march
okay and uh antiva had made an actual
people say it's not a real thing well
they had a flyer
and it said black bloc anarchist
everyone meet at this park so it's this
circle the i think it's like jefferson
circle or something
i don't remember what it's called they
all meet together so polish state media
probably
not super hyper aware of what's going on
in the streets of america
goes to film then i start seeing they're
like on the outskirts the black blocks
start coming up you know saying you
can't film here
you can't do this and they're saying i
can film whatever i want wait you guys
have freedom of press here you know in
their accents you have freedom of press
i know my rights here i know what i can
do and another journalist who's american
media i'm not going to say where from
was saying oh no you obviously don't
realize the rules of antifa so
they're going uh you know journalists
saying that they follow the rules of
anarchists
uh and so then it goes further the guy
goes he's getting a kick out of him he's
a pull right pulls don't mess around
so he's just like keeps filming and he's
like luke and
they're pushing up a couple times police
are there and they're pushing the camera
guy
and they're hitting the camera and the
police are standing there and
this is i mark my words i spoke to these
guys the next day i i did hear it right
i filmed this incident it was on twitter
they're pushing him back pushing him
back into the police and he's telling
the police why don't you help me
and the officer was like dude well you
shouldn't have been accosting them and
he's like
i wasn't accosting them i'm filming them
like i'm with i'm a press member like
look and the
officer was like dude look man just
don't be bothering them and you're like
was that election night
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah how did how did
this flip happen
where it's like the left has been
screaming the proud boys walk up to a
cop and shake their hand and they're
like the police are practicing
protecting the proud boys and now it's
inverted yeah a very similar thing
happened to me in hamburg when i got
jumped by antifa
police officer came looked at me he was
like uh we can't help you you're screwed
good luck
and then literally i got followed back
and and you were there and it was just
the crazy insane inside
the crazy the crazy thing is how the mob
mentality works like some dude just
pointed at luke and accuse him of being
a fascist and then random people run up
and start punching luke in the head
you know i saw something i saw a video
of yours old school video bro
i thought it was awesome from one you
were i think you were in new york
i don't know where you were but you were
covering antifa
and it it it kind of shocked me because
i think antifa was literally like on the
sidewalks and i was filming them like
i think it's when you guys wearing out
tires and you got hit for the first time
when you got assaulted i was there too
the first and i remember a guy walking
because no no no no that was the second
time but i remember the second time was
also kind of prominent because i
remember
i saw this guy walking behind you i'm
like he's going to jump off he just said
something
and then and then no no no no i was like
i was getting ready no i think it
weren't no yes
i was filming matt grabbed him and i uh
oh that's right
and i grabbed his mask off and took his
mask off and then
it was absolutely what year was that
what year was that was 2012 it was the
beginning of 2012.
this is what stuck out to me what stuck
out to me was how antifa i remember
hearing like police calls on the
intercoms
in the video what stuck out to me was
how antifa would actually listen to
orders to get on the sidewalks in march
is that accurate would they literally
march on the sidewalks yeah of course of
course uh
and now that now they're just the whole
well it's about choosing their battles
right at the time back then it was like
you want to fight for the cops to do it
covertly
don't let them arrest you arbitrarily so
then you know they would do things like
de-arrests
cause it was anarchy what's weird is is
anarchies like the police are against
you but now the police
protect them i actually okay this is a
weird way to segue but i actually
brought a gift for you guys i'm being
serious this is a rare gift i'm not even
joking
this is only like a couple of these
around i want you to open this it's not
inappropriate on air oh boy i want you
to
know
it's not inappropriate and i really want
you to keep this this is actually a
historic
historic piece it's a story piece i only
have four of these
i'll explain you what this is so this is
a hat that i saved out of a bonfire in
ilhan omar's district
during the trump rally when the police
cordoned all of the
trump supporters uh to walk through the
antifa and they were ripping everyone's
hats off
and lit them on fire i took a few out of
the fire and put them out
and saved them to remember the violence
and the abuse that was going on and i
remember during that time when i was
filming that
you know people were saying like why
aren't the police doing anything this
was like a shock at that point
saying how could the police be
protecting those who are assaulting
trump supporters and i go well
clearly this shows you that the police
while many officers
are great individuals who just love
their city and they're trying to protect
and serve or just make a living
this shows you that that police are
under the influence of their district of
their city and there's a lot of
bureaucracy and political
corruption that's involved in what
police can and cannot do and when i
watched that and that's why i kept these
hats i think the only person who has one
is glenn beck
thank you sir but i wanted you cause i
knew you'd actually keep that definitely
that's that's a relic to show you
like that's a failure of the police in
our state right now where the fact is is
that if that can happen if people can
get their property stolen
illegal fires could get lit and guess
who i kept seeing getting arrested for
fighting back
trump supporters of course of course so
one of the first events i went to i've
been covering we didn't we didn't call
them antifa back during the occupy wall
street days we called them black block
anarchists or whatever
but they're not anarchists like i was
friends with the anarchists you want to
know why
because anarchists real anarchists be it
left
anarchists or right anarchists don't
believe in using violence against people
yeah
the non-aggression principle i'm very
very left libertarian i don't believe in
you know anarchy is anne without archie
authority i'm not that
you know far libertarian in on the
spectrum but i'm pretty left libertarian
on a lot of issues
and so i was hanging out occupy wall
street and i'll tell you
the actual anarchists were complaining
the whole time saying
sitting down having a discussion like
convincing people of how we all work
together and cooperate
is anarchy not one person beating the
other
demanding they do as they're told that's
fascism that's authoritative that's what
they were saying
the left using force and extersion to
push your ideas is something that's bad
i mean that's
widely accepted by a lot of anarchists
and there was a lot of very interesting
smart discussions
at occupy wall street which i think you
know i think that that kind of sentiment
this is interesting because we really
have to talk about the kind of political
climate right now
because i bet there's going to be a lot
of left wingers that are going to be
very disenfranchised with joe biden
there's also a lot of right wingers that
are absolutely pissed off at the
authorities
especially the police officers this
saturday it was ezra levant
posting even admitting himself rebel
like a conservative very conservative
a canadian a canadian not complying with
the law
exactly uh which is which is absolutely
fascinating but there is a political
realignment
the climate is changing and i think
there's going to be some major fireworks
especially
this year well so i guess what's going
to happen is i think you'll start seeing
i wonder if uh we have these we have
these three factions i wonder if the
populists
will have a tacit agreement of some sort
right so this is something that gent
yuger of the young
turks wrote about recent uh recently he
said there's three different realities
there's
the populist left the establishment and
populist right well he
he claims to be a populist leftist i
disagree i think he's actually very very
very pro-establishment
and i think he just you know his bread
and butter is the progressive track i
really do think so
you look at like you know jimmy dore who
was saying like why can't we get a vote
for medicare for all and this is the big
big scandal going on right now jenk
huger and jimmy were trending on twitter
earlier
so anyway digress he's right he's right
and so you know i'll give him respect
for for
this op-ed he wrote the one thing he got
wrong was very derisive of trump
supporters saying they're cultists and
stuff like that
you don't need to go there because you
can just talk about the populist left
hates the establishment
the populist right hates the
establishment with trump being pushed
out of power
that means you're gonna have two
out-of-power populist factions who hate
the establishment if there's three
realities here
and two of them are united in their
hatred of the establishment
will anti-fun the leftists look the
other way when proud boys are the ones
you know yelling
at cops and screaming and the proud boys
announced that this specific week that
we saw this in a post by enrique talking
about maybe we should wear all black
maybe we should not identify ourselves
as prod boys so that's also another
contributing factor to what's kind of
happening here and how it's unfolding
because i really do think the
establishment is deathly afraid of these
sides coming together because they're
going to realize they have a lot more in
common than they have
different from each other what happens
when proud boys and conservatives do
show up
tomorrow on the six and the or tomorrow
or on the six and they are
in black block that so if those aren't
affirmative it's like they're wearing
you know black sweaters and black pants
and masks or whatever
you won't be able to tell the difference
between anti-fun and proud voice and
smell yeah
what are the police gonna do what are
the cops gonna do yeah yeah and what is
how is antiever gonna fight proud boys
if they look the same how are proud boys
gonna fight antifa
i suppose if you're in disguise as
antifa you know
i'll hit somebody else but what if a
proud boy punches a proud boy thinking
he's antifa
the point is i got knocked down in
seattle i wasn't i was in block
and a proud boy once punched me in the
shoulder and knocked me down
from the shoulder punch well he went
like he's a oh you don't know some of
these dudes
yeah well i was just standing there i'm
not like in a defensive position i was
just standing
like boom and i just like why did it
like fall down i just was like whoa and
like
i was like damn i was like no wonder why
this antifa get knocked down
[Laughter]
what'd you say what'd you do afterwards
oh i was like dude i'm not like antifa
even though i'm dressed as antipa how do
you do that
yeah but that's that's that's that's the
why they dress in all black because they
want to create confusion yeah yeah
but so there was a tactic it's a very
important tactic so they don't get
recognized by the police officers
because they're out they all mesh
in and we saw this tactic not just used
in the united states but also very
prominently in hong kong
where they use black block tactics to an
amazing extent
to a point where they don't even have to
assault the press they just have a team
of umbrella people come around
and set up this huge umbrella circle
around them and they
and they never assaulted journalists
they never told them not to film they
just set up these umbrella things and it
was way more difficult
yeah and they were able to galvanize a
lot of these people i mean in hong kong
they're literally protesting for their
lives
there's people disappearing right now
from china because they made a facebook
post or a social media post against the
chinese government
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you